this is Jocko podcast number 234 with
echo Charles and me Jocko willing
good evening echo good evening so I was
working with some national on front
clients the other day talking about
leadership and I was talking about the
minimum use of force have you heard that
phrase before yes they have so we talked
about it from sort of uh combatives a
tactical perspective but I was talking
about it from a leadership perspective
meaning that you want to lead you want
to lead most of the time with a minimum
use of force so I want to do as little
as I can to make you do what I want you
to do that's that's a good rule of thumb
to lead with I was also thinking and and
this is you might I don't know if you're
gonna find this funny you might I was
thinking about leaders being legit you
know have you noticed I use the term
legit yes I use it more now you've
you've acquired it I've acquired it yes
and and we know what it means right we
use the term to mean like that's cool
but it's a little bit stronger right mmm
means kind of approved yeah
but then I was thinking about the you
know the source of that word legitimate
because once again I was talking about
leaders being legit and actually beyond
that leaders being legitimate leaders
think about that right think about the
difference in your mind when you think
of a legitimate leader or someone that's
an illegitimate leader there's a huge
difference because when a leader is
viewed as illegitimate then they're not
respected they're not listened to if
someone gets put new position because
they're the boss's favorite or because
they backstab someone right to get into
that to get that promotion they're not
going to be considered legitimate a
legitimate leader and that hurts their
ability
to lead so as I was thinking about these
two things the minimum use of force and
legitimacy and I recognized both those
thoughts in my head from the
counterinsurgency manual FM 3 TAC 24 now
here's a little history behind this
manual when I arrived in Ramadi yeah
this is the this is the manual that I
read when I arrived Ramadi so what
happened was I arrived in Ramadi I went
to an Intel briefing during the Intel
briefing there was this massive link
diagram of all these bad guys a bunch of
them connected how they were connected
who they were connected to some of the
bad guys had little red slashes through
maybe they'd be killed or a little green
slash to him meant they'd been captured
but the thing is this massive link
diagram didn't really look all that much
different as the link diagram that I had
left and Baghdad two and a half years
prior so in my mind I kinda realized
wait a second if we're still doing the
same thing and things don't really look
all that different this isn't good and
well it seems like we're losing so I
don't know what necessarily thing
triggered my brain to go and read the
counterinsurgency manual I must have
seen something I used to read all these
and still do I'd read you know these
sort of military websites and you know
military news and those kind of things
and somewhere in there I had seen that
this new this new Field Manual is coming
out and I knew that this new Field
Manual had been written by General
Petraeus and general mattis both those
guys need no introduction both grab
leaders very very well known inside the
military when I was in and and now both
of them are well known outside the
military and that reading this so I so I
went and googled it on the regular
Internet and so now this is like May
yeah this is May of 2006 and I'm trying
to remember
I don't think I saw the whole completed
manual I think I saw on a brute of
either
I think I saw chapters of it and I did a
little research and it turns out that
van they did they had sort of assembled
the initial chapters and released them
as quick as they could just to get this
information out there and when I read it
it definitely shaped the way I thought
about the Battle of Ramadi it shaped the
way that task unit bruiser could operate
in the battle of Ramadi and really it
ended up shaping the way I think about a
lot of different things about leadership
and business and the teams and and life
and so I actually dug around the
internet and I found one of these early
versions so one of the versions that I
found of this it's it says on it
FM 3 TAC 24 and it's June 2006 that's
when this this is the final draft so I
think I think the thing I read was
probably just a little bit earlier
probably one of the few chapters
released and also when I read that I
read what I read and again I wish I
remembered it better what I read I read
the whole thing and when you see the
whole manual it's 250 pages and there's
a lot of stuff that gets into stuff that
wouldn't have been as pertinent to where
I was and what I was doing so I think I
probably saw the first two or three
chapters of this and I absolutely know
for a fact that saw the first chapter
which is what I want to dive into today
now this is this is what this is what
made me want to dive into this believe
me this is one of the first manuals that
I wanted to cover I said oh you know I
should cover the field I should cover
the counterinsurgency field manda we
should go and read that well here's the
deal it is a huge manual right and a lot
of it digs into the weeds and kind of
gets really granular on you know how you
do logistics inside it so there's a lot
of really deep not deep snot the right
word there's a lot of very tactical
techniques that you're gonna use to make
things happen inside of a
counterinsurgency
but what I find fascinating about this
is the way that it relates to absolutely
everything
it's especially from a leadership
perspective especially from a leadership
perspective because you start thinking
about things you start thinking about
the way the world is formulated and if
you think about it from an insurgency
and a counterinsurgency perspective you
start to see things much clearer and the
reason is because let's face it if you
if you want to take a look at things you
want to say oh war is comparable to
everything right everything is
comparable to war it could is it
possible to say that okay
well it's possible to say that but if
you don't include insurgency in that and
counterinsurgency in that look war is
not always especially in business
especially inside inter inside of a
business inside of a team is it really a
war when you know I'm trying to get some
of one of my subordinate teams to do
what my other subordinate team is doing
and they're giving me resistance is that
war is that an all-out war not really
hmm it's more like an insurgency and
what I've got to do I can't just go to
war with them if I go to war with them
I'm going to destroy them that's the
goal of war insurgency means I'm gonna
form relationships I'm gonna bring
people on board I'm gonna get rid of the
people that are bad actors like it's a
totally different much more nuanced
thing and that's what allows you when
you can put when you can look at things
through the prism of insurgency and
counterinsurgency it gives you it will
give you some it will give you some
visibility on how to handle situations
so it's real easy to say ah we're at war
with our competitor okay I get that
we're at war with our competitor we're
gonna go to war with our competitor
we're gonna go to war with this other
team but when you say hey we've got
people inside of our own organization
that don't agree with what we're doing
all of a sudden it takes on a totally
different meaning because if you go to
war with them what do you do you destroy
them can you
can you effectively and perfectly
destroy only the things that you want in
a war no war means there's gonna be
collateral damage means people are gonna
you know it's it's a it's a gnarly thing
so but insurgency and counterinsurgency
is more nuanced it takes more you have
to use a scalpel instead of using a
battle axe right that's what you're
doing and so when you start seeing
things as an insurgency and acting as if
you're utilizing counterinsurgency
procedures to try and solve that problem
it's a much more accurate way of saying
hey everything in life is comparable to
war okay does everything in life
comparable or maybe but that's not what
I'm saying what I'm saying is this
allows you to make much better analogies
like that yeah I'm not saying that's
perfect I'm not saying everything in
life is war know this allows you if
there's a war analogy if there's a war
metaphor there if there's things to be
learned from war you have to learn from
the insurgency and counterinsurgency
mindset so let's get into this it's and
and I want to make sure that I I kind of
point some of this stuff out as we go
through so here's the foreword this
manual is designed to fill a doctrinal
gap it's been 20 years since the US Army
published a manual devoted to
counterinsurgency operations at 25 since
their Marine Corps published its last
manual with our soldiers and Marines
fighting insurgents in both Afghanistan
and Iraq it is thus essential that we
give them a manual that provides
principles and guidelines for
counterinsurgency operations and they
call that coin such guidance must be
ground in historical studies however it
must be informed by contemporary
experiences so what's cool about this is
and they reference the counterinsurgency
and the insurgency in Iraq in 2005
like that's how up-to-date this thing
was and they were trying to get this
information out there as quick as they
could this manual takes a general
approach to coin the Army and Marine
Corps recognized
that every insurgency is contextual and
presents its own set of challenges so
guess what every little disagreement
that you have inside your team has its
own little contextual things that are
happening in its own set of challenges
so you have to be able to adapt to that
you cannot fight former Saddam as' and
Islamic extremists the same way you
would fight the Vietcong the Morrow's
which is a Philippine let's call
insurgent group or the Tupamaros which
was in Uruguay the application of
principles and fundamentals to deal with
each vary considerably and it goes on to
say that nonetheless there's common
characteristics of insurgencies it says
a counterinsurgency campaign is as
described in this manual a mix of
offense defense and stability operations
conducted along multiple lines of
operations so that right there if you
take that little thing right there into
your mindset because if we just say
we're going to war what does that mean
it means optimally we're just going on
offense maybe we say we're all about
offense but we'd have to go on defense
sometimes but then stability like what
does that mean if that means you're
trying to keep this whole organization
together hmm right you're not worried
you're not worried about this when I'm
going to total war with echos country
I'm not worried about stability for you
I'm worried about just destroying you
I'm going on offense and then conducted
along multiple lines of operations so
that means there's all kinds not just
fighting it's not just guns
it requires soldiers Marines to to play
a mix of both familiar combat tasks and
skills more often associated with
non-military agencies with balance
between them depending on the local
situation this is not easy
leaders at all levels must adjust their
approach constantly ensuring that their
elements are ready each day to be
greeted with a handshake or a hand
grenade what
what does that do to your mentality I
mean just think you're going into a
meeting you got to be ready to deal with
the handshake or a hand grenade that's
what you've got to be ready for mm-hmm
to take on missions only infrequently
practiced until recent years at our
combat training centers to be our nation
nation builders as well as warriors to
help reestablish institutions and local
security forces to assist in the
rebuilding of infrastructure and basic
services and to facilitate the
establishment of local governance and
rule of law that's what you throw the
military into all that stuff that's why
counterinsurgency is so hard yeah just
everything I just said going to war is
like the easy part here's the bad guys
go kill him that's the easy part
everything else I just said that's what
makes this so complicated conducting a
successful counterinsurgency campaign
thus requires a flexible adaptive force
led by agile well informed culturally
astute leaders probably the opposite of
what the stereotypical military person
is is our hope that this manual provides
the necessary guidelines to succeed in
such a campaign in operations that
inevitably are exceedingly difficult and
complex our soldiers and Marines deserve
nothing less and it's signed David H
Petraeus Lieutenant General US Army and
James n mattis Lieutenant General the
United States Marine Corps
so there's your introduction right out
of the gate you can see we're dealing
with something totally different just
infinitely more complex
chapter 1 and this is the only chapter
we're gonna cover today and it may be
they look like I said it gets into some
very granular stuff but this is such a
good opening chapter 1 insurgency and
counterinsurgency counterinsurgency is
not just thinking man's warfare it's the
graduate level of war Special Forces
officer in Iraq 2005 and this is what's
what's really cool about this is the
Battle of Ramadi is seen as a model of
counterinsurgency and I was lucky enough
to be there and lucky enough to sit in
Brigade Brigade op orders and division
op orders and to sit with the the
brigade commander and listen to what his
thoughts were and hear what the input
was and here I mean it just was I was so
lucky to be a part of this to be there
so starts off overview insurgency and
counterinsurgency are subsets of war
though globalization and technology and
and technological advancement have
influenced contemporary conflict the
nature of war in the 21st century is the
same as it has been since ancient times
a violent clash of interest between or
among organized groups characterized by
use of military force success in war
still depends on a group's ability to
mobilize support for its political
interests and generate sufficient
violence to achieve political
consequences means to achieve these
goals are not limited to regular armies
employed by a nation-state at its core
war is a violent struggle between
hostile independent and irreconcilable
wills attempting to impose their desires
on another it is a complex interaction
between human beings and is played out
in a continuous process of action
reaction and adaptation war
this manual is available for free on the
interwebs google it I'm not gonna read
the whole thing today I'm gonna hit some
highlights says this also its scale and
complexity should never this time well
counter-insurgency its scale and
complexity should never be
underestimated by leaders and planners
indeed the possible scale and complexity
must be understood before the beginning
of any such operation this is a mistake
we've seemed to make over and over again
you think you're the big badass American
military we're gonna go in there we're
gonna squash these these enemy soldiers
and the peasants will be on board you
know the local populace will be on board
when they see the freedom and we just
underestimate this thing all day long
you underestimate how hard it is to do
this how hard it is to actually execute
a a counterinsurgency talks about a
couple different aspects of insurgency a
couple different kinds our revolution
which they described as an unplanned
spontaneous explosion of popular will
another one as a coup d'etat which is a
small group of plotters that replace
state leaders with little support from
the people at large and in an insurgency
as an organized protracted political
military struggle designed to weaken
government control insurgencies normally
seek to either overthrow existing social
order and relocate power within the
country talks about internal Wars as the
name internal Wars implies these are
primarily conflicts within States not
conflicts between states and they all
contain at least some element of civil
war that's why I think so much of this
is potent to being a leader because so
much of being a leader isn't about how
you're taking the fight to the enemy
it's how you're handling the people
inside your own country that's what's
hard handling the people inside your own
company handling the people inside your
own organization let me tell you
something
a daschle on front where we do
leadership consultant
we spend at least as much time helping
solve the problems inside the company as
we do helping companies figure out how
to solve what they do to beat their
competitors because if you don't have a
squared-away organized situation inside
your team you're not gonna beat the
competitors
you're not gonna defeat your enemy so
this counter insurgency these these
encounter insurgent tactics are what you
use to help your own team stay unified
and if you don't utilize them correctly
guess what you get you get an insurgency
and at worst it rips your team apart but
even if it doesn't rip your team apart
it has you rowing in different
directions and when you go in different
directions you don't know where you're
supposed to go so you need it you need
to keep a check on that one possible
exception to this rule involves what can
be termed a liberation insurgency where
indigenous elements seek to expel or
overthrow what they perceive to be a
foreign occupational government such a
resistance movement could be mounted by
a legitimate government in exile as well
as elements competing for that role well
another thing that happens in business
businesses get bought this is get bought
by bigger businesses businesses have
people get inside and take over there's
hostile takeovers there's all these kind
of situations and then you get these
little insurgencies inside companies
inside businesses inside teams also it
can be outside actors get involved fast
portala in all cases of the long term
objective for all side remains
acceptance of the legitimacy of one
sides claim to political power by the
people state or region so if you're a
leader and you are in a company and
you're not considered legitimate uhat
you're you're basically out of the gate
you're probably to be dealing with an
insurgency yeah that's just how it's
happening mm-hmm it's gonna be rough
another little section here the scale
and complexity of coins should never be
underestimated the effort requires a
firm political will and extreme patience
on the part of the government it's
people and countries providing its
support widespread security requirements
also limit flexibility again ceding to
ceding the initiative to insurgents
there's all kinds of reasons that the
insurgents have an advantage right Oh
another court here the contest of the
internal war is not fair as most of the
rules favor the insurgents most of the
rules favor the insurgents in Iraq they
absolutely did do Julian did the
insurgents in Iraq care if they wounded
some friendly civilians not one bit did
they care if they killed each other
not one bit did they use torture
absolutely did they use terror
absolutely did they do the most brutal
and savage things to the local populace
yes they absolutely did and they didn't
care at all so they have a complete
advantage when it comes to the rules any
whether you're talking about the
tactical rules or the actual rules of
engagement or the law of armed conflict
they don't care about any of that the
insurgent can make exorbitant promises
and point out governmental shortcomings
caused by the insurgency so yeah so you
make a mistake fighting an insurgency
they're gonna use it to their advantage
you you kill civilians by accident oh
that's gonna be a you know national news
world news global news they're gonna
take advantage of that and they want
that to happen
fast forward coin is not an approach to
war that can be classified simply as
foreign internal defense it features a
full spectrum of operations including
stability operations like any other
campaign in all cases however
insurgencies will not be defeated simply
by killing insurgents since the
insurgents since the insurgent begins
with strategic initiative meaning they
have an advantage the counter insurgent
is usually involved initially in more
defensive than offensive opera
that's the way it kind of kicks off
they're attacking you you don't even
know who they are
victory cannot be gained until the
people accept the legitimacy of the
government mounting coin and stop
actively and passively supporting the
insurgents that right there I was
smiling when I read this because that's
one of the quotes that I just completely
ripped off from this when I read it for
the first time and I started using that
all the time you know I started saying
well you know when my boss would ask me
you know what are you guys trying to get
done observe you know we're trying to
we're trying to stop the passive support
that's happening for the insurgents and
all of a sudden I sounded smart stole
stole stole words from them
because that's what all there was a lot
of in Ramadi in Ramadi there was local
populace was so scared that if an
insurgent came into their house and
wanted to use their window to shoot -
their sniper rifle from they would just
like get out of their way give them some
bread you know we don't want to bother
you you do what you got to do we're not
we're not here to cause you but with me
they provided passive support yeah and
that happens inside companies too you
know you get the whatever that one
element that used to be here that gonna
help you they're gonna give you a hand
they're not definitely not gonna rat you
out because they see that illegitimate
leader that whatever stepped in you just
want to keep their job a lot of time yep
exactly they want to make any waves
right let me clean this gives a good
section that kind of talks about the
histories of insurgency so that's why
it's worth pulling out this book each
insurgency is unique although there may
be similarities among them in all cases
the insurgents aim is to force political
change and this is important to trying
to read my note here forced political
change but actually sometimes especially
in business the goal is to prevent
change right they don't want some new
system they don't want some new
procedure so they have a little
insurgency to fight against they're
fighting against change
specific types of insurgency here's some
things that you're supposed to try and
figure out what's the root cause of the
insurgency how important is that right
if you're in a team and you're in a
business you're in a leadership position
and there's some kind of an insurgency
happening
you feel that find out what the root of
is where is this coming from
next extent to which it enjoys support
both internally extent and externally
who's who who's on board with us basis
on which insurgents appeal to target
population insurgents motivation and
depth of commitment where they act like
how much does this mean to them likely
insurgent weapons and tactics
operational environment which insurgents
seek to initiate and develop their
campaign so there's some things to look
at and and this is why this again this
is what I think this is important
because if you just look at your own
team and you just think oh they're
against me I'm at war with them it's a
problem the way you fight that war is
not going to be correct if you look at
it as an insurgency you say ok how do I
actually assess this and this becomes
this gives you such a strategic
advantage
several different types of insurgents
some of them seek to completely change
the existing political system anarchists
egalitarian traditionalist pluralists
they got good little definitions for all
these in there some do not seek total
political power to state these are
secessionist reformist preventionists
commercial estándar got to try to figure
out what it is that your insurgents are
seeking insurgent strategies you've got
conspiratorial conspirators
conspiratorial strategy involves a few
leaders and a militant cadre or activist
party seizing control of government
structures or exploiting a revolutionary
situation this is what's interesting
such insurgents remain secretive as long
as possible emerging only when success
can be quickly achieved that's
definitely something to think about
because you think everything's going
cool right you hear a little bit of
murmur hear a murmur there someone's
talking about this method that we're
using someone's against some way some
change that we want to make here little
whispers and then all of a sudden one
day boom you get hit in the face with it
and you weren't ready for it so you got
to watch out for that military focus
these are ones that are gonna use
military force to try and make things
happen
urban organizations like the Irish
Republican Army and Latin American
groups and have pursued an urban warfare
strategy approach uses terrorist tactics
and cities to sow disorder and create
government repression those such
activities have not generated much
success without wider rural support you
also got the protracted popular war
that's an I said it's just an ugly tore
term protracted war what does that mean
it's gonna last
a long time and what sucks is from a
psychological standpoint like if you and
I are gonna train jiu-jitsu and you know
that I'm just a guy that's just gonna go
protracted again like you don't want
none of that right I tend not to hate
well let me let me let's say you set up
the clock the timer and you put five
minute rounds on there and then I walk
over and I just turn it off there's no
time limit it's just gonna be a
protracted war its core going and I
don't care how long it takes yeah I was
thinking of doing a is there still is
there a jiu-jitsu tournament right now
that's no time limit submission only
does one exist right now I don't know
we've had some variations of it
attempted yeah but is there anyone
that's doing no time limit no submission
only I think there's certain ones that
have like those types of matches but
they're I think they're specific like
special matches like no time limit
matches or something like that it's not
all of them but it's actually it's
pretty rare but yes I've seen that what
if we do a jiu-jitsu tournament called
protracted war yeah sure
the thing is you got to be ready you
gotta be ready fluid about this as a
competitor as a competitor you're like I
got a hydrate because I might be
fighting for the next nine hours well
that's what the UFC was did series or
the first ones well how many how many
before they made the time limit 16
minute time limit with like a overtime
so uh it was one and two I think and
three something like that
so you'd have to do this I had an idea
you do because you got to figure most
matches aren't gonna last like nine
hours yeah very few matches would last
nine hours I think I think very few
matches would go over an hour but
occasionally you would get to just
really evenly matched humans and you
know how hard it is to submit somebody
that's good yeah but if you had three
mats running at the same time and they
were all had a note
limit protracted war on each one of them
so that way if you have an audience that
wants to see this they can watch
whichever one is this happening because
let's face it some of them is gonna get
you know the guys gonna get a position
and he's just gonna start grinding in
somebody down but it might take two
hours yeah I mean if I got if I was in
if I was going against you in this
tournament and I got a cross side it
would be a long time yeah I would be
there for a long time yeah I wouldn't
rush it I would cook you for a while
sure yeah why would I rush
yeah no reason the and I think that was
the whole thing about jiu-jitsu to begin
with like hey you know Helia Gracie's
you know smaller guy you know and he
lets that you know he can put himself in
safe position positioning take minimize
damage all this stuff and then the guy
gets all tired and then he can use his
you know leverage or whatever like there
was a lot of them his matches old-school
over one hour yeah when they had no time
limit but you got to be ready for that
yeah as a competitor but as far as
tournaments go as an audience member to
you got to be ready for that yeah well
that's why maybe you're doing it with
multiple matches going on at the same
time and that way you can you know you
can kind of highlight the big the match
where there's action happening but I
watched a I don't think it was no time
limit but it was one of those ones I
think was like a 30 minute time limit it
was like a super fight and one of the
early tournaments that I did and they
were super good they're both really good
so they're even and like none of them
even scored a point on each other and
after a while I was like bruh this is
this I like jujitsu a lot but it's kind
of boring yeah that's that's that you
know what the problem is there the time
limit the time limit because when you
have a time limit you're like oh well I
was training yesterday I was like mmm
there was something like 40 seconds left
I could see it on the clock and I was
fighting I was rolling with Andy and I
was like fighting to keep him and you
know from passing my guard and then you
know there was like 32 seconds left and
I was like hey man even if he passed my
guard right now you know he's chances
are
he's not gonna finish me so I'm not
saying I let him pass because he
definitely passed it but yeah you don't
know I kind of like within lot lock my
hands and I kind of sat there and I like
you know even he knows it yeah it wasn't
he's laughing he's like smiling or
whatever he said yeah so that's in your
head yeah so when you when you're in
these things you have a time limit
you're like whatever I can I can I can
hang out for another 7 minutes yeah not
just just don't expose anything but if
there's no time limit the different
mentality so when you're going into
those protracted wars if you're the if
you're the insurgent bro you live there
yeah you live there for your life now so
so you don't care how long you know when
we when we fought Vietnam yeah when we
fought in Vietnam
the Vietnamese they're not going
anywhere they're not there at home right
you know we have to go over there when
we're fighting in Iraq they're at home
the insurgents are there they live there
there was foreign fighters of course but
Afghanistan same thing so they have this
weapon on their side which is time the
protracted war this is gonna sound kind
of off but I was watching this he was
like a 1 it wasn't a documentary but you
know the kind of where it's like on like
Discovery or one of these and then they
they proposed like what if this happened
huh you know like there's a show called
what if humans disappeared or something
like that
ever heard of that we're OK after you
know 10 years the cities would start to
get down and after and they have the CGI
and it's pretty cool so there was one
where it said what if aliens took over
mmm and how would we beat them because
if aliens took over they that's what
they would be they wouldn't be like oh
let me just come and live with you guys
they that's what they're saying
chances are chances are they're they're
not benevolent yeah not to help people
they're here for Earth you know kind of
like I mean think about it that's every
living thing it's kind of like where I
live here now kind of thing
so anyway they're saying how would we
fight the aliens and their say they're
breaking it down like this is what the
aliens would do first this is what they
do second this is what they do third
they've just totally breaking down as
like thing but they're saying at the end
of it at the end of the day the best way
we could win is through I think they
called it guerrilla warfare or maybe I'm
sure it's insurgency I forget what they
called it but that's what they would say
it's like we live here so we have that
advantage of like we can hide for you
know mutts and then attack and then go
hide again you know because we live here
meanwhile they're here so it's like
they're here they got to run supplies
from their own yeah whatever
alien spaceship yeah and they got to
make moves and they just dragged me into
a protracted conversation about alien
invasions losing this war over here it's
the exact metaphor though you know like
where if like aliens are coming over
whether it be to take over or to get
some alien job done bro we live here we
don't you know we can take hits this is
the thing that's ridiculous about this
argument is what level of competence
does the alien do the aliens have mostly
varying levels of competence okay so if
they're let's face it we could get
invaded by aliens that were not that
advanced and we would just kick their
ass real quick
like on the district nine or something
like that I don't know but I don't I'm
not familiar when where did that battle
take place South Africa what was who
were the insurgents aliens
I don't know the insurgents were I guess
that's not really no it's a new
situation yes sir okay I thought you're
talking about an actual wartime
situation that I was unaware of oh yeah
the aliens came down yeah I don't know
but yeah in that movie yeah I guess you
know district 9 was not about any kind
of insurgency at all it was more that
show what was their confidence
what was their company that aliens yeah
basically it was like aliens I don't
know I forget why they were there no one
really knew why they're there but it's
essentially the ship didn't it didn't
crash but it sort of got jammed up and
they were sort of stuck there so they
would they find after a few months or a
month or whatever they they were the
humans people went up and with their
helicopters because the alien ship kind
of came didn't crash just hovered and
stayed there didn't open didn't nothing
so they go up and they explore they open
the alien craft this is pretty good good
show
anyway they open it and all the aliens
are all starving and freaking you know
they're messed up like they're desolate
you know God and so they're like hey
well they're not hostile so what do we
do just leave I don't you know so they
set up these camps for them you know
they'd help help them or whatever so the
aliens were kind of quarantined they
were but lack of food lack of food so
they kind of shuffle supplies but rather
sort of aliens you know like I don't
know what do you know you can't just let
them live with us because they're kind
of whatever so spend in that situation
so it was less about fighting or it was
less about that it was one about some
other issue yeah and I guess you'd have
to figure that if an alien element maybe
here they're pretty advanced they got
some technology so I don't think we're
gonna be coming up against the the JV
team no right that's what that show was
saying the JV team isn't gonna show up
on earth no right because how did they
get here they designed some kind of a
spaceship yeah I got here these are some
these are some Elan musk level smart
well then again technically a sure that
but that does that indicate or does that
does that prove that they're gonna be
squared away in all ways you know maybe
they just have this new technology they
can do this stuff but yes you can make a
spaceship that can get here I mean you
had to you had a fight to get here this
was not easy yeah but that's a different
kind of fight when you think about it
this is insane it's kind of like you
know oh maybe they're just people that
if Majan if they just didn't even have
the concept of violence right yeah just
was war this was totally foreign to him
yeah and so they could show up here and
the first one that you know tries to do
something somebody just hits him in the
head with a bat it's all Shaw ya'll
confuse what but is that even possible
that there's a group that just has no
comprehension of violence if there is
you know what they'd be they'd be aliens
because he and I seem saying things work
differently seems like cool you know how
like um every once in a while like
you'll get a situation where I don't
know this turned into grounded
right something real like ambiguous
actually right now but let's say okay
let's say you're you're the alien you go
to a distant planet you're like we're
gonna take over so we're gonna we're
gonna bring this poison this poison is
like the most least lethal poison ever
created here so we're gonna take this
and we're just gonna exterminate them
all like that's how so we're gonna go
and then you go to this distant galaxy
you go to their planet whatever perfect
fruit you know perfect just like Earth
whatever and you go you start spraying
this poison and they're licking it up
yeah they're like oh my gosh it solves
like a bunch of their problems and make
some super you know it's like that kind
of situation I'm just saying it doesn't
prove that just because they know how to
travel through dimensions or whatever
doesn't mean they're gonna be successful
in everything you see I'm saying it
could be it could be the opposite right
on
all right well protracted war that's
where we're at is this Mouse theory of
protracted war outlines three-phased
political military approach strategic
defensive this is where the enemy and in
this case you're flip-flopping back and
forth and who's the enemy but the enemy
meaning the government has stronger
forces so you're in defense then
stalemate where you're doing guerrilla
operations and then offensive is when
you actually have beat down the
government forces enough that you can
actually have a real war with them
almost like a conventional war and then
it talks about how you can go these
stages you can go you can go through one
stage you can skip a stage you can come
back to the stage so that's what happens
we're protracted war it's very hard to
speaking of protracted war it's very
hard to get the submission on the
insurgents because every time you get
him get him in a chokehold they slip out
and they slip away right and now you
can't go and find them because they slip
back in with the local populace so
you've got to kind of you know check for
that
so that's protracted popular war they
got traditional many contemporary
insurgencies fit a more traditional
approach based on clan tribe or ethnic
group such insurgency typically has an
entire community join the
as a whole bringing with them their
existing social and military hierarchy
the primary struggle in an internal war
is to mobilize people in a battle for
legitimacy and I think that word
legitimacy and legit is one of the thing
that made me start thinking maybe has to
do the counterinsurgency manual because
think about how often that happens in an
organization the leader is either
legitimate or not and if you're if
you're not considered a legitimate
everything is hard yeah and if people
think you're legitimate everything is
that much easier so when you are acting
as a leader and you do things that
negate or detract from your legitimacy
you're doing a whole lot more damage
than you think you are hmm every time
you use your authority in an abusive way
your legitimacy goes down every time you
tell a lie your legitimacy it goes down
every time you do the right thing your
legitimacy goes up like you know when
people will say I demand respect you
know like that thing you automatically
just lost respect yeah kind of right
yeah is because that it's not really
held by the way you need have to say
that you can just act like that mmm just
act like you demand respect yeah like
just call me sir damn it kind of thing
I'm not saying there's anything wrong
calling someone serve or whatever but
you know that kind of stuff like they'll
harp on that kind of stuff like you can
tell someone's reaction when they're
reacting to this detail where it's like
oh you know like I see what you're doing
I know you're basically saying like I
ain't never sex I'm not gonna I mean me
earning it that's a whole different
thing
you see I'm saying but you you just
better give it to me kind of thing so
it's like one of those you know if
you're illegitimate that tends to be
like what it looks like if you're
legitimate it tends to not be what it
looks like it's just a good little
framework to think
to filter your actions through does this
make me more or less legitimate
mobilization means there are five means
to mobilize popular support persuasion
coercion reaction to abuses foreign
support a political motivations a
mixture of them may motivate anyone
individuals so persuasion political
social security and economic benefits
entice people to support one side or the
other this is where you're like hey
we're gonna take care of you coercion
this is the carrot and the stick right
persuasion is the carrot coercion is the
stick you either get on board with what
we're doing or we're gonna give you a
beatdown
reaction to abuses this one is important
a government that abuses its people or
is tyrannical generates resistance to
its rule think about that from a
leadership perspective think about all
those three things from a leadership
perspective you can either use
persuasion you can use code so carrot
stick and then reaction to abuses so if
your abuses if you abuse people as a
leader they're gonna have been injured
maltreated victimized dishonored or had
close friends or relatives by the
government particularly by security
forces may lash back at their at her at
their attackers so when you're abusive
to people it's gonna come back at you it
adds fuel to the insurgency so you've
seen the insurgency will use that oh
yeah I like that that's how you get
people to come on board if I show your
house smells like hey echo I was real
sorry to hear about your brother yeah I
know I'm really started hear about your
brother I can't believe that they did
that yeah I can't believe the government
security forces did that to your brother
do you want to fight back yeah here's
what we're doing you see where I'm going
with us so that what does that mean that
means that when you're fighting an
insurgency you can't add fuel to that
fire you have to be very careful yeah
and how you act towards the populace
because the populace because the
insurgents will utilize your abusive
actions to bolster their cause
foreign support obviously you can have
people on the outside that like to see
that love that want to support some
insurgent inside of a country a
political motivations these are teeth
here's criminals mercenaries people
attracted by the holy warriors romantic
status and others who self images of
being a warrior and a fighter
for a cause might also join insurgency I
think you saw a lot of that nicest
people that were just criminals mm-hmm I
just wanted to go get get crime on yeah
I mean it wasn't like they were
promising a whole bunch of nice stuff in
in the Islamic state yeah well other
than authorized rape of you know women
children girls and boys they're always
you know I'm not gonna say how I saw
this but I saw some Isis promo videos
like promo like yeah I don't know that
they were recruiting videos oh no it's
in some of those too but it was like a
promo like an advertisement for this
cool like club kind of thing I was like
dang it oh wait were they ones that were
like insanely violent no so they were
just kind of real positive yeah and it
would show like yeah they were probably
there was a there's a whole bunch of
them and yes they're the insanely
violent one that were kind of like
produced a little bit you know that was
yeah that was kind of odd it was like
weird
um cuz I don't know who they were
marketing to I mean I couldn't relate to
the audience that they were marketing to
will say that but yeah and the other one
the nice one was odd because of like
what everything else they've been
putting out you know then it was like
almost like this utopian commercial yeah
that's the that's a crazy world of I
guess social media you might have you
heard my new term for the social media
yes
emotional media it's not only for social
media it's actually all my cuz every
media right now is just emotional media
how can we make everyone's
hyper-emotional what story can we show
to make everyone freaked out
let's do that what video can I tweet or
share on the gram
to make people get super crazy oh yeah
let's do that
you know which one can we can people
retweet that's a big one
whether it be like all K this is like
super retweet a bowl because you're
gonna get all fired up and then you're
gonna say something long lines in your
head you can say something long lines up
of can you believe this guy said this
boom retweet everyone who agrees with
you boom they're gonna feel the same way
hopefully retweet too you know it's also
actually some people that weren't really
thinking about it see that and they go
wait yeah oh yeah
they get emotional yes and then you get
a whole millions of people yeah
next little sections is about causes of
causes a principle or movement
militantly defended or supported
insurgents may create artificial
contradictions using propaganda and
misinformation insurgents have much to
gain by not limiting themselves to a
single cause insurgents employed
deep-seated strategic causes as well as
temporary local causes adding or
deleting them as circumstances demand so
you get this sort of whatever your
whatever your a problem is with the
government like if you're an insurgent
in Iraq people are people that you know
not only do they say well well in Iraq
it was oh you know the the bath is have
been in charge forever and not only that
but we don't have whatever you know we
don't want there we don't sell our oil
we don't we don't get enough money for
our oil whatever grievance you have
becomes part of something that we adopt
yeah and that can happen inside any team
right what starts off as you know if
you're mad you know I'm telling I'm mad
because we're using a new method and
you're mad cuz we didn't get a pay raise
guess what now we got it boo both I'm
mad about both now I'm gonna stop you're
damn right we need more money
yeah and that's how the insurgency's
grow they start adopting all these
different problems yeah all these
different causes unify them into one
giant cause yeah so like solidifies the
like and
oh yeah that's the enemy versus us any
country ruled by a small group of that
bra without broad popular participation
provides a political cause for
insurgents exploited or repressed social
groups by the entire DEA entire classes
ethnic groups are small elites may
support larger causes in reaction to
their own or narrower grievances so
again as a leader when you're looking at
your team in eternal sea that you might
be getting multiple causes turned
against you next sections about
mobilizing resources and obviously
insurgents well resorts are tactics such
as guerrilla warfare and terrorism not
only because of their disadvantages
manpower organization but also because
they usually begin with limited or
inadequate resources compared to the
counterinsurgency so that's why you end
up with guerrilla warfare asymmetrical
warfare they talk about money they talk
about insurgency and crime sustainment
requirements often drive insurgents into
relationships or the organized crime or
into criminal activities themselves this
is absolutely true I know the Iraqis had
all kinds of crime going on all right so
the the insurgents had all kinds of
crime going on smuggling in black
markets and the whole nine yards to try
and pay for what they were doing and
then you know in Afghanistan they got
this massive drug trade to support the
insurgency so that's definitely
something that can be problematic
elements of insurgency leaders
combatants political cadre auxiliaries
and mass base leaders control the
insurgent movement they are the idea
people and the planners they usually
exercise leadership through force of
personality the power of revolutionary
ideas isn't that interesting the power
of revolutionary ideas edan it kind of
interesting like you always hear me talk
about how I was a rebellious kid and I'm
even I'm I was rebellious in my Navy
career with
I was rebellious I always have that kind
of rebellious thing but this the idea
that the power of revolutionary idea of
revolutionary ideas there's like a
natural human kind of there's a natural
human draw to that and you know what my
best example of that which you my friend
will give me a full salute and credit
for hey you know what it is
hmm what is the what is the insurgency
that you think of that everyone is drawn
to and everyone supports ever just about
every human being supports one
particular insurgency Star Wars what's
up the movie yeah the movie who are the
what's the name of the rebels Yeah right
there revolutionary that's what's
happening yeah why does why do these
revolutionaries why does Che Guevara you
don't have this t-shirt that everyone
cuz he's a revolutionary right people
like that this is this some weird it's I
guess it's can be kind of like rooting
for the underdog maybe there's some kind
of some kind of attraction to that yeah
that just naturally exists that's why
when we watch Star Wars no no one says
hey I hope the Empire wins right there's
no one's saying that even the name the
Empire I see I see what yeah what's
going on there I mean that it's the
American Revolution right the
revolutionary ideas yeah people like
that kind of thing yeah yeah under I
mean that's a common oh why yes you know
I'm as I'm thinking through it
psychologically you know what you like
about it
you know what's naturally attractive
about it you take all your grievances in
life mmm right I don't don't make enough
money I didn't end up where I wanted to
end up my girlfriend dumped me my
boyfriend dumped me I don't like my
house I don't like my car I don't like
my apartment what
grievances you have you can package all
those things up and you can point a
finger at them and you can say those
things are all wrong I'm being
revolutionary over here yeah yeah yeah
and you identify with that I mean back
to the movie thing where you identify
regards I really you know you're the one
who said Star Wars so you think what are
they call just the rebellion where they
called the rebels the rebels yeah rebels
rebel based in the Senate yeah yeah and
you support them they're the underdog
versus them yeah but that's most that I
don't want to say most movies cuz I
haven't seen most movies but that's a
lot of movies the underdog crasher it
kind of to be on it seems like all of
them like Rock Karate Kid frickin Brede
I don't know named Rambo I don't know
yeah whatever movies you watch or
whatever
yeah the underdog yeah so those are the
leaders they're gonna capitalize on the
power of revolutionary ideas is it even
in marketing right even in marketing
people like this is a revolutionary new
pair of sneakers or phone or whatever
right everyone is attracted to that idea
remember on Rambo First Blood Part two
missed that time where he was hiding in
the wall oh yeah it wasn't why was the
mud is the mud wall essentially in the
didn't you know in Vietnam whatever and
like he opened his eyes you could only
see his eye and then he'd like undoes
his fingers first you know and he comes
out and kills everybody that at the time
was a revolutionary idea
oh we hated the mud rate that was kind
of the way he did it you see the same
right I think you just I think you just
nailed it but is captured at all it just
captures all we're less combatants
combatants do the actual fighting and
provide security there's the political
cadre the cadre is the political core of
the insurgency they're actively engaged
in this struggle to accomplish the
insurgent goals auxiliaries are active
sympathizers active sympathizers who
provide important support services and
then you get the mass base and these are
followers of the insurgent movement
supporting the populace and again so
inside
your organization inside your team you
can identify who these people are when
there is an insurgency going on right
there's the leaders of it that kind of
guess they have this advantage if
they're standing up to the man right
there revolutionary they got a little
advantage there
there's combatants that are actually
gonna try and make things happen there's
this cadre that's out there kind of you
know running their mouths and sowing
seeds of discontent there's then there's
sympathizers and the mass base so if you
can identify who these people are you
can realize what you need to do to
disrupt this insurgency from happening
and isn't it weird that as we talk about
this I just had this instinct right now
even in my own head but it's right now
as we're having this conversation even I
sympathize with the insurgents in I like
talking like I'm thinking about oh I got
this new idea and the man and all that
stuff that's real yeah that's real stuff
that you feel yeah maybe I do you think
it's cuz we're American or is it a
global thing like are we American that
were raised hey you know we're we're
Americans were revolutionary we rebelled
against the king
maybe ate our own country we won't stand
for this kind of you know what I mean
that's America
yeah there's but the thing is it's
universal I feel like it's universally
yeah because it's kind of like the our
need for balance so you get like someone
who's just starts out their starting
point as an underdog whether it be in a
movie or in life or just in a any
certain situation that you're presented
with if someone feels like an underdog
it just feels like an imbalance of some
sort power imbalance and whatever kind
of imbalance so we kind of part of our
mind I think anyway that's what it feels
like when I experienced it part of your
mind kind of wants it to be more
balanced we want him to get out of that
underdog situation so when he does it's
like it's almost like a feeling of
satisfaction you know it's almost like
it feels like justice or something there
it's like it feels so unfair unbalanced
at this the empire's we just like see
nothing wrong with yeah that's it that's
what it is what why it is I think that's
what it feels like I guess that's what
that's the traditional heroic
that's what it is you know it's the it's
the traditional it's one of the
traditional whatever there are for a
relic journeys one of those heroic
journeys is you know David and Goliath
the little guy stands up to the big guy
and then we all appreciate that
there's the rocky four with Drago is
there oh yeah yeah for now is a good
dynamics of an insurgency you've got
leadership objectives ideology
environment geography external support
and sanctuaries phasing and timing
leadership we know about the one thing
they say is extreme decentralization
results in a movement that rarely
functions as a coherent body
so usually insurgents insurgencies are
super decentralized which means they
have a hard time sort of coordinating
mass mass movements together
objectives they gotta have clear
objectives they got there by the
ideology and narrative narratives a a
word that gets thrown around all the
time
what's the story that we're telling yeah
right and how do we fit everything into
the story that we're telling ideas are a
motivating factor in insurgent violence
insurgencies gather recruits in a mass
popular support through ideological
appeal recruits are often young men
suffering from frustrated hopes and
unable to improve their lot in life it's
what I just said yeah the insurgent
group provides them identity purpose and
community in addition to physical
economic and psychological security
I mean how just blatantly obvious is
that the movements ideology explains its
followers tribulations and provides a
course of action to remedy those ills
again back to that balance thing you
know where we kind of want that like
think about this to where okay there's
this place I don't know where a hireling
it was in Ireland I don't think I don't
know it was somewhere where you get like
criminals bad criminals murderers like
rapists type guys or whatever and the in
jail and it's not even called jail I
don't think it's it's essentially a
rehab center but in the rehab center
this is what you get you get like
pets and you get it's essentially like a
for therapy to rehabilitate them so
there's punishment and then there's
rehabilitation right they focus on no
punishment
it's just rehabilitation and apparently
from what I read or whatever it's like
pretty successful that's good um here's
the thing though with that it feels
super unsatisfying because you get a guy
who raped you know a lady killed her and
then killed the husband or something
like that for example he goes no
punishment he goes to this place where
he gets pets he gets um he can hang with
girls he can he makes friends he gets
like he learns like stuff skills and
stuff like that he doesn't he's not
locked in a cell he's that a little bit
like a little resort kind of thing even
even murderer even murderers yeah yeah
hundred percent so yeah there's no
punishment part of it so what so where's
the no satisfaction coming well if that
the person the victim of this criminal
is like your wife or something and this
guy gets to go to a risotto you're
saying they the victims have no
satisfaction at seeing this
rehabilitation take place exactly they
want to go blood for blood yeah it seems
like that imbalance still remains
because this guy gets to improve his
life after he killed my wife
meanwhile sure it's murderers and
everything yeah that's what I read
that's why problematic I don't know how
well that would work here yeah we get
some you get some vengeance going down
oh yeah but here was the thing in the
point of the article was that there was
um like the what do you call it when you
go back to like you go to jail then you
get out then you go back to jail it's
like reseted going back to jail
yeah it's like relapse kind of thing the
rate was so astronomically good that no
one went back to jail it was like that
it was like it was so effective at
rehabilitating the person but meanwhile
when you think about it man there's
still this massive imbalance so people
wouldn't be very happy with that assumed
saying yeah but as a society like as a
whole as far as groups as far as
criminals getting rehabilitated which I
mean how can you be against criminals
being rehabilitated it's hard to be
against that you know but we still don't
get that satisfaction we need that you
know it's like that imbalance imbalance
well I I just back to this year just
this idea that you have and it loses
it says you know young men you know
that's who that's what we're talking
about we're talking about young men that
are that are unable to improve their lot
in life and this is you how how you end
up with these people getting drawn into
these super usually extremist type
organizations the most powerful
ideologies tap latent emotive concerns
of the populace such as the desire for
justice religious beliefs or liberation
from foreign occupation ideologies
provide a prism including a vocabulary
and analytical categories through which
the situation is assessed thus ideology
can shape the movements organization and
operational method you know it's
interesting you start tracking on that
what did they call it here vocab just
vocabulary is what they call it but you
know you track any sort of organization
that's out there that sort of has a you
know you look at some some things you
know that's kind of got a weird cult II
feeling to it one of the main things
that give something a cult II feeling is
when you hear the vocabulary that's all
being used and it's all not just used
but it's used as like this weird kind of
way to answer any questions and circular
arguments it always comes back to these
things and you're like well this is
getting kind of funky over yeah oh yeah
very strange environment in geography
external support and sanctuaries these
are all just really getting into some of
the details I will stop at this one
though phasing and timing insurgencies
often pass through common phases of
development not all insurgencies
experience such phase development and
progression through all phases is not a
requirement for success so there's
different phases that you can go through
and like I said earlier and this way you
got to pay attention you don't have to
go through every face you don't start at
face want to go to Phase two then phase
three and then you defeat it at phase
three no you can still go back to Phase
two you defeat phase two they go back to
Phase one then you think oh I think
we're under control then they go to two
again the next so they go back and forth
you got to pay attention to that
talks about insurgent networks here's
some of those insurgent phoner abilities
secrecy because they got to keep a
secret sometimes they have trouble
getting the word out their mobilization
it can be hard for them to to mobilize
support for for a couple reasons
one of the things they talked about here
is to mobilize their base to support
insurgent groups use a combination of
propaganda intimidation and they may
overreach in both counter insurgents
should be able to use information
operations to expectedly exploit
inconsistencies in the insurgents
message as well as their excessive uses
of force for intimidation so definitely
in Iraq the insurgents went overboard in
trying to intimidate people and it
pissed off the local populace and it
definitely pissed off the sheiks in the
Battle of Ramadi like they got pissed
and some of them left fled someone got
scared but someone got mad and the local
populace was saying well as soon as they
saw that there was enough American
presence and Iraqi government presence
to say okay thank you for being here
will help you get these back get bad
guys out they were on board mmm
financial weakness it's tough for them
to find funding internal divisions this
is an important one to pay attention to
counter insurgents must remain alert for
signs of divisions within an insurgent
movement again when you're dealing with
a group of people and they're all masked
against you look for those cracks look
for ways that they're not sort of in
unison and if you can exploit and expand
those cracks all of us and you can break
down that there unification which is a
positive thing and it isn't it we again
I have this little guilty thing in the
back of my head that's a cat
I don't want to break down you know the
the rebels right cuz I've been
programmed my Star Wars to support the
rebels and by the American Revolutionary
War that's who I identify with we
identify with the rebels I'll tell you
an example of that you've watched the
matrix and I know this is I know
you know he heavy this yes I've watched
I like saw it one time in the theater so
I don't remember much about it so
there's this guy I forget his name the
guy from bad boys anyway you know him
he's actor um yeah I definitely know
them anyway it doesn't matter so
basically he's so you know what the
matrix is about right everyone's plugged
in the matrix and then meanwhile
Morpheus Laurence Fishburne Morpheus
saves all these people from the matrix
right and they're the real reality you
know the only thing I remember this
whole movie is when I think the main
character says jujitsu
I know jiu-jitsu that's what I remember
yes yeah you're trying to get that
download yeah you got that yeah for sure
so Morpheus plots everyone everyone out
of the matrix matrix is like everyday
life you know just took up a job and
whatever you're living life or whatever
when you get plucked out of matrix the
real reality is a straight-up dystopia
straight up machines running everything
you're living in you know in a
post-apocalyptic times so this one guy
it starts to weigh on him apparently
and he's like brought on even like this
I kind of liked it better in the matrix
being ignorant so he ends up teaming
with the agents which is like the agents
of the matrix drebber eyes that roll
around and in betraying the rebels
that's what that is right there that
wouldn't when you get you find little
slight divisions and then you exploit
them you know and and he he he ran the
risk of bringing down the whole team
soon saying wait which team did you know
Morpheus in the team but he wanted to do
that right yeah yeah so he didn't run
the risk he could have yeah wasn't risk
to him he wanted to yeah yeah I'm so
does he take the blue pill is that right
no he wish he said and this is what
indicates that there was a fracture in
it just a little bit of a division when
he it was like one of the early scenes
with them he was talking to Neil the
main the one that the main cared and he
was like you're thinking this I'm
paraphrasing he's like why didn't I take
the blue pill he was like saying like oh
I know what you're thinking you're
thinking that meanwhile I don't know if
that would be you know the blue pill
like you stay in the matrix bright red
pills you see you know so basically he
was indicating that he was sort of
thinking of like that he regretted it a
little bit kind of thing you know that
was like the little fracture that they
showed in the story good then yeah so
yeah they almost know they almost lost
but you know matrix Morpheus meal their
very problem powerful they were able to
keep it real
this is the Hollywood podcast okay with
echo Charles and echo Charles aspects of
counter surgery this is so all that kind
of it I hate to say that was like the
introduction but this is where we get
into aspects of counter insurgency this
so this is how we actually overcome the
insurgency in almost every case the
counter insurgent faces a populace
containing an active minority supporting
a government and a similar militant
faction opposing it and they kind of lay
out all it looks pretty much like a bell
curve whatever the cause there will be
an active minority that totally supports
the cause there'll be a neutral or
passive that's the majority of people
are just hey we don't really care and
then you've got an active minority
against the cause which this is
something important to think about in
life especially in well-liked right now
in America yeah the you who do you hear
from you hear from the to way far
extreme ends of the spectrum everyone
else is just hope you know just trying
to live a life and do the right thing
and feels you know considers things sort
of as a group you know like all pretty
much the same hey this is this yeah this
makes sense this doesn't make sense this
is smart this isn't smart and then
there's people on the spectrums I mean
on the outside of the spectrum that are
jumping up and down screaming and
getting crazy yeah they are not the
majority of humans their small number of
people but boy they make a lot of noise
they call them what the vocal by annoyed
yeah yeah the silent majority yeah I
think so silent majority was Nixon
originally said that
upon assuming coin mission soldiers and
Marines must not only be prepared to
identify their opponents and approaches
to insurgency they are applying counter
insurgents must also understand the
broader strategic context which within
which they are operating so you need to
think about the bigger picture obviously
historical principles number one
legitimacy is the main objective the
primary objective of any counter
insurgent is to foster the development
of effective governance by legitimate
government all governments rule through
a combination of consent and coercion
now think about that from a leadership
perspective all leaders just think of I
said all leaders rule through a
combination of consent and coercion that
makes sense right
you're coercing people to do and they're
consenting they're saying okay we'll do
it
governments described as legitimate rule
primarily with the consent of the
governed while those rule does
illegitimate tend to mainly rely on
coercion like making and forcing people
to do things which you probably heard me
say this a special on front events you
know when I I'm always saying well I
never really had to order anyone to do
anything
mmm-hmm we would just kind of talk about
it and things would happen why because I
was legitimately in these positions I
wasn't there just I I got I I have the
rank and that's why I miss position like
no I have some experience I listen to
other people like that's what's good
citizens obey the state oh this is
talking about the illegitimate so if
you're an illegitimate leader the
citizens obey the state for fear of the
consequences of doing otherwise rather
than because they voluntary voluntarily
accept its role a government that
derives its power from the governed
tends to be accepted by the citizens as
legitimate so if you're if you're
elected right if that's where you got
your power from then it's usually
considered
it still uses coercion for example
against criminals but the bulk of the
population voluntarily accept its
government governance in Western liberal
tradition a government that derives its
just powers from the people and
responses desires while looking out for
their welfare is accepted as legitimate
so that's your goal as a leader and
anytime that you rely on a leader on
your rank on your authority on your
power anytime you're doing that you're
taking away from your legitimacy mm-hmm
legitimate legitimate II makes it easier
for the state to carry out its key
functions which include the capability
to regulate social relationships extract
resources in appropriate and appropriate
or use resources in determined ways
governance that is not legitimate is
inherently unstable because as soon as
the state's coercive power is disrupted
the population ceases to obey it this is
when you hear me talking about hey you
might be you know if I if I bark and if
I'm your boss and I say echo you better
wear your gloves when you're in this
compound or I'm gonna fire you hmm
right you're gonna do it but when I'm
not there you're not gonna do it yeah
wait yeah so this is why that type of
leadership doesn't work coercive
leadership threatening people that's why
it doesn't work it's not freakin
legitimate yeah five indicators of
legitimacy can be used to analyze
frequent selection of leaders in a
manner considered just and fair by a
substantial majority of the population
thank you
that includes pop promotions right if
people are getting promoted for good
reasons that makes sense then they're
considered to be more legitimate a high
level of popular participation in or
support for the political process a low
level of corruption when you as a leader
do things that you know are right well
you make little maneuvers that you
shouldn't be making guess what your
level of legitimacy
you maintain the high ground a
culturally acceptable level or rate of
political economic and social
development a high level of regime
acceptance by major social institutions
the governments that score high in these
categories probably have the support of
an adequate majority of population as as
leaders that score well in these areas
are also going to have a high level of
support military action can address
these sips symptoms of a loss of
legitimacy
however restoring legitimacy can only be
accomplished using all instruments of
national power without the host nation
government achieving legitimacy coin
cannot succeed so you can beat people
down all day long that doesn't give you
legitimacy you can solve tactical
problems with military might with brute
force doesn't help you do you can't win
you can't win with that ain't it crazy
to think this big military manual you
cannot win with just military force you
cannot beat someone into submission it
doesn't work well it doesn't work on a
long long term scale a couple other
things here unity of effort is essential
that's true with any leadership
political factors are primary one of the
generals from Mao Zedong's Central
Committee once stated that Revolutionary
War was 80% political action and 20%
military action 80% of it is a political
action 80% of it is a maneuvering
understand the local environment you
have to do this here's a couple the
local population is critical center of
gravity of an insurgency successful
conduct of counterinsurgency operation
depends on thoroughly understanding the
society and culture within which they
are being conducted soldiers and Marines
must understand the following about the
population area in the area of operate
how key groups of society are organized
relationships and tensions above them
ideologies and narratives that resonate
with the groups group interests and
motivations means by which groups
communicate the societies leadership
system and what's so funny about this is
a national on front when we go and
consult with a company these are the
things that we're trying to figure out
during our assessment phase we're trying
to figure out okay we figure out how
their task organized what's the one of
they set up like then we start going one
of the relationships where are the
tensions mmm then what narratives
resonate with the group with the
different groups right you've got the
frontline leaders that are saying oh
they never do that you've got the senior
leadership that's saying oh well what
would they know you see what I'm saying
there's little narratives that we're
trying group interests and motivations
you got to know what those are means by
which the group's communicate what how
do they actually talk to each other is
there an open line of communication so
these are all things that we look at to
figure out how we fix leadership inside
of a company do you um do you do that
because like did you get that straight
from here or do you just happen to do
that and boom there's a parallel well we
don't just happen to do that in order to
solve the problems inside of a company
you have to understand these things
right but you you know you knew that for
sure
yes yeah and so what did you get it from
that I get what you're saying
no I didn't get it but when you know the
way bromby you see it and all this yeah
and I'm sure as I worked with companies
you start saying well how's your
relationship with that department over
there you know and and hey so explain to
me what you think where you think the
company's going right now what's the
what's the narrative it just lines up
yeah because you have to figure these
things out do you go in kind of like
good cop bad cop you know what you don't
have to you don't have you don't not bad
cop yes because everybody knows that
we're there to help right there's no
we're not trying to bust them we're
trying to help ray tells two people tell
us everything that they you know they
they they're very open and honest with
yeah do you do you ever do like little
sly things like and I guess I shouldn't
say sly because you know how like if
you're really trying to ask this
question but you can't just come out and
ask that question because you can't
expect them to just come out and give
you that straight dope answer you so you
kind of ask these other questions to
kind of get affirmed what you want to
know is are there interrogation tactics
that are being utilized when you're
interviewing the personnel that we are
consulting question yes of course you
know but I mean it's not there you're
right that they're not sly right it's
like we're getting information from
people that they want to tell us it's
not it's not we don't have to set them
up or roamers them to say things or we
don't have to we talk to them yeah
here's what the advantage that we have
is people want their company to be
successful yeah
and so when you ask them hey what works
well they tell you when you say hey are
there any issues they tell you because
they want they want to have those issues
fixed this isn't the easiest part of the
job is gathering this information
knowing what information to gather is
important but the easiest part of the
job is gathering this information
because people are over there just
they're just more than happy to tell us
what's going on yeah yeah make sense a
couple things that are required of
soldiers and Marines at every echelon
when you're when you need to know about
the cultural context you've got to have
a clear nuanced and empathetic
appreciation of the essential nature of
the conflict so you've got a here and
listen to both sides wouldn't that it
doesn't that make sense
yeah and hunt and essentially like have
some understanding yes like hey and
empathy yeah yeah like I can see how
you'd get that you think that I can see
where you're coming from yeah that's a
good idea to have in your head for life
or like living for being a human it's so
true like the idea that like someone
just doesn't get where that person is
coming from it's almost like bread
that's just because a lack of effort you
know yeah and here's the deal
you're missing out you're me you're
missing out if I argue with you and I
don't listen to what you're saying and I
don't see what your viewpoint is there's
no way I can defeat you in an argument I
don't understand you how can i defeat
you an argument unless I understand
where you're coming from and and not
necessarily even defeat you how can I
find a solution if I don't understand
where you're coming to feat you in an
argument that's what you do when you're
20 that's what you're doing you're 23
defeat people and arguments when you're
hopefully by the time you're 48 like me
you actually don't want to defeat
someone you want to find a solution yeah
there's a lot of arguing that happens
just broadly yeah I mean right now we're
seeing it all day long every day in in
the emotional media social media
mainstream media it's just total no
listening all talking no perspective no
empathy it's well I shouldn't say no
because there are a lot of people that
are actually listening trying to figure
out what the solution is but but many
people they don't want to try and figure
out what the solution is they want to
defeat the other person in an argument
which is so pointless so then you need
to understand the motivation strengths
and weaknesses of the insurgents that's
obviously important you want to conduct
intelligence drives driven operations
meaning we want to actually pay
attention to what's going on when a
gather good Intel isolate insurgents
from their cause and support smart move
establish security under the rule of law
the cornerstone of any coin effort is
security for the civilian population and
this is probably the number two line
that I stole from this Thank You general
mattis thank you General Petraeus
because when I had to start discussing
up the chain of command what we were
doing why we were doing it it was this
line right here the cornerstone of any
counterinsurgency effort his security
for the civilian populace because what
we were doing task unit bruiser was
going out and killing bad guys
in order to protect the civilian
populace and that right there is the
cornerstone of counter insurgency so we
were able to just get all of our
missions approved up the chain of
command because what we were doing was
in support of the cornerstone of of
counterinsurgency thank you for getting
those chapters out early enough that I
had this to lean on illegitimate actions
this is just some illegitimate actions
by government officials security forces
and multinational part partners are
those involving the use of power without
authority oh wow
power without authority when you use
power without Authority or you abuse
power you you illegitimate self every
action by counterinsurgency leaves a
forensic trace that may need to be used
in a court of law
counter insurgent all their activities
to preserve wherever possible a chain of
evidence and more importantly as a means
to insurgent propaganda this is epic and
I'll tell you why because inside
businesses you make some little move you
make some little move and you think no
one's gonna know it hmm
but it leaves a forensic trace and and
that's just a different way of saying
you know you know I am always telling
people everyone's watching you and if
you try and lie to them they know it
that's what's happening that's 100
percent what's happening you try and lie
to somebody they know it you try and
make a maneuver on somebody there's a
forensic trace and they know it don't do
your little maneuvers to try and take
care of yourself prepare for a long term
commitment back to that protracted war
idea
here's some contemporary imperatives of
counterinsurgency managed information
and expectations achieving steady
progress towards a set of reasonable
expectations can increase the
populations tolerance for the inevitable
inconvenience entailed by ongoing
counters on counterinsurgency operations
so just setting good expectations
setting good realistic expectations and
then moving towards them so you can look
around at the team and say hey look
we're making progress this we're going
and this is our get in there we're
making progress
both the insert both a counter insurgent
and host government ensure that their
deeds match their words do what you say
say what you do here's the other thing
that triggered me into talking about
this use measured force any use of force
generates a series of reactions there
may be times when an overwhelming effort
is necessary to intimidate an opponent
or reassure the populace but the type
and amount of force to be applied and
who wields it should be carefully
calculated by a counter insurgent for
any operation an operation that kills
five insurgents is counter
counterproductive if the collateral
damage of of the creation of blood fuels
or the creation of blood feuds leads to
the recruitment of fifty more now this
was a little bit strange because there
was some of that idea that oh every time
you kill an insurgent you create five
more I would definitely hear that I
didn't see it what I actually saw was
the opposite when we would kill an
insurgent the local populace would be
like okay it was it was they'd gotten
bolted they got braver they got tougher
they gave us more support why did they
say that in the war or what was their
thought the thought is hey you know and
you know if you kill if you they see you
kill you know some kid some some some
some family member right some family
member gets killed and you think okay
well we just created there's five
brothers right
and now they're mad but actually
oftentimes it was like hey don't follow
what Freddie did yeah we know why we
know he was doing bad stuff he got
killed
mm-hmm and they kind of got it and I'll
tell you what they also to a huge extent
understood collateral damage the local
populace understood collateral damage so
if we blew up a building or blew up a
door and we entered a building and it
shattered the windows and it turns out
that we should you know it was either
the wrong building or whatever and we'd
say okay you know what
hey here's a bunch of we'd give him a
bunch of money we'd apologize we'd say
what happened explain to him and they
would be like yeah well you are at war
yeah you know they and they would and
this is how I know that this is real as
they'd give us information yeah they'd
say oh yeah you I know you're looking
for you're looking for that guy yeah
he's he's been gone for two weeks
yeah and then we'd say yeah thanks but
you know it's our fault here's some
money
yeah it's weird how like to hear it you
know cuz you know you get whether it be
reports or like it usually is from
someone someone who has a different I
don't want to say agenda necessarily but
you know like if someone's like against
the war or something like that's kind of
their their their deal you know so
they're kind of trying to input nothing
they're trying to convince that and I
don't want to paint this you know
beautiful picture cuz obviously there's
there's there's obviously times where
you know the there's one of those
brother gets killed and one of the other
brothers says I'm gonna go avenge or you
go veg but you know what if think about
in a family right the mom and dad
there's four brothers one of the that
one of the brothers is out doing
insurgent stuff and he gets killed
yeah the mom and dad are looking at the
other brothers going hey do not go and
do what your brother does that happen
all the time no not all the time
sometimes the you know the dad says will
avenge you know we're going and your
brother right not usually yeah yeah so
and then yeah the point is to where you
you from the outside you kind of hear
someone's are
well that makes sense yeah just like I
said where it's like yeah the brother
got killed if your probably got killed
you at the very least have some feelings
of vengeance the very lease not to
mention people who live in a war zone
who are down for the fight a lot of the
time right you're gonna see their
brother get killed there you be like
hell yeah I'm gonna come to come avenge
that that does it stick out as a lie
it's so yeah and it is true the problem
is it's very simplified yeah right
because because what's really happening
what's really happening is the dad is
going hey do you remember Saddam Hussein
he was horrible these Americans came and
kicked his ass and got him out of here
and and and now we're moving in the
right direction now you want to go fight
them what's wrong with you and then that
guy getting sup getting killed and the
chemos looks at his brother's head you
see what happens yeah yeah and seeing
when you explained that you're kind of
like whoa that makes a lot of sense it's
real easy just a stereotype and throw
everyone with a broad brush and say oh
they're they everyone thinks like this
yeah it's totally not true man nothing
at a family there'd be some people kids
would be insurgents some kids wouldn't
yeah and that's not to mention like some
of the terror that these normal families
have been you know absolutely inflicted
on them and then it's like yeah okay
when you say they understand collateral
damage it's kind of like you the way you
said is almost like and which is
actually correct
from my perspective where it sounds
obvious everyone understands collateral
damage you know like everyone kind of
understands that you know but so why
would we assume that they don't like
everyone should exactly so when you say
that you're like we we dehumanize yeah
humanize that local populace and think
oh they're just there here's a common
emotion you blow up my door I'm mad
gonna fight you now when it's really
when actually dealing with human beings
and we people forget that we're dealing
with human beings that are smart and
they think oh you blew up their door now
they're gonna want to plan a roadside
bomb no actually when you vote their
door and you say hey we were looking for
this guy
and he wasn't here do you know where he
is you know he's been gone for two weeks
hey sorry about your door here's some
money
by the way we're gonna send a team out
here and behind
new door for you which we did yeah and
they go yeah I appreciate it yeah you
know please please let your friends know
that there's no bad guys that live here
and by the way the only problems we've
had on the street is that building down
there
there's been some people in and out of
there you might want to keep an eye on
it okay cool thank you yeah and see you
mean hearing that it's like brother that
makes in fact that sounds more likely
you're in that situation you know that's
what I'm saying so this idea that every
time one you know you kill a person you
kill a bad guy that now five more it's
totally untrue and not not to mention
there's some people that I know she's I
don't want to go get involved with that
right yeah I mean that's what that's it
there's a high deterrence level there's
a very strong deterrence level because
what what people miss out on is just the
like you said and the way I always
explain Iraqi families I'm like oh you
want to know what Iraqi families like
they're like a family yeah they're like
a family and there's be you know the
dad's got this and the moms got this
going on and the kids and they you know
they've got a rebellious kid right
you're going to one of the war rooms and
there's like weird pictures of whatever
you know Iraqis movie stars I mean you
know music stars and like it's they're
just they're just people and we just
paint them with this broad brush of how
we think they will react or how we've
been told that they'll react and it's
just not true gotta learn and adapt well
before I go there who wields force who
wields force is also important providing
the police have a reasonable reputation
for competence and impartiality it is
better to let police and these are
police that are local police handle
urban raids rather than soldiers and
Marines even if the police are not as
well armed or as capable as military
units since the populace is likely to
view that application of force as more
legitimate so you want the Iraqis to
handle their own problems now in Ramadi
there was what made it tricky is a lot
of the Iraqi army soldiers or Shia and
the local populace in Ramadi was Sunni
that's why as quickly as we could we got
the Sunni policeman
Iraqi policemen that were from Ramadi to
start doing these kind of things because
there was more in some cases not in all
cases in some cases there was more
tension between the Shia soldiers and
the local populace than it was between
the Americans and local boppers learn
and adapt that effective counter
insurgent force is a learning
organization right back to our podcast
we did with Dave Burke good deal to
empower the lowest levels mission
command is the conduct of military
operations through decentralized
execution based upon mission orders for
effective mission accomplishment what
does that mean it means higher
commanders empower subordinates to make
decision with the commander's intent
they leave details of execution to their
subordinates and require them to use
initiative and judgment to accomplish
the mission decentralized command thank
you support the host nation and what the
little part I wanted to pull out of this
support the host nation thing is
American forces committed to coin are
there to assist a host government the
long-term goal is to leave a host that
is capable standing on its own two feet
to feed in that end the host nation has
to win its own war achieving this
requires the development of viable local
leaders and institutions US forces and
agencies can help but host nation
elements must be able to accept
responsibility to achieve real victory
and then it goes on to warn that you
can't you can't be the easy button when
something needs to happen you can say
okay well what are American so we can
make that happen
no you need to actually not be the easy
button and
this is one of the last sections here
it's called paradoxes of the counter
insurgency which if I would have named
this section would become being called
the dichotomies of counter insurgency
but you know what we're saying
principles and imperatives discussed
above reveal that coin presents a
complex and often unfamiliar set of
missions and considerations for a
military commander in many ways the
conduct of the counterinsurgency it's
counterintuitive to a traditional
American view of war and that right
there that statement is why I'm saying
if you're gonna start to overlay warfare
principles in your business in your life
you need to also include
counterinsurgency in there because
sometimes they're counterintuitive
sometimes they're different than
traditionally the way you think of war
and I think this attitude this whole
attitude is so important to be able to
take war fighting and overlay it into
other scenarios if you only know how to
fight a conventional war of attrition
you can't overlay your those principles
over the rest of your life they won't
work all the time they're not nuanced
enough they don't understand they don't
understand the complexities and one of
those complexities is there's paradoxes
and there's dichotomies number one the
more you protect your force the less
secure you are what does that mean do
you have to take risks and when you take
risks when you when you get outside the
wire when you go work with the local
populace the more secure you'll end up
being so as a leader if you stay locked
up in your office you feel like you're
safe in there because you're not out
there you know getting engaged with
people not to ask tough questions that
the less secure you are you need to get
out there next one the more force used
the less effective it is boom when
you're barking orders when you're you
know yelling at people when you're when
you're saying you better do this or I'll
fire you what whatever those things are
the more force you use as a leader
less effective is when you use the
minimum force required that's the most
powerful the next is the more successful
coin is the less force that can be used
and the more risk that must be accepted
so as you proceed down the path you need
to use less and less force and you have
to take more and more risk which is
crazy the initial reaction to the
counterinsurgency push and Ramadi was
enemy attacks are going up and American
casualties are going up and guess what
it was true so some people up the chain
of command not not my chain of compile
at yes all up the chain of command
everyone was saying wait there's more
what's happening there's more enemy
attacks there's more American casualties
this isn't working no actually that's
exactly what's gonna happen hmm
sometimes doing nothing is the best
reaction often an insurgent carries out
a terrorist or guerrilla act with the
primary purpose of enticing the counter
insurgent to overreact or at least react
in a way that can be exploited
if a careful assessment of the effects
of a course of action concludes that
more negative than positive effectual
result an alternative should be
considered potentially including a
decision not to act now this is you know
well default aggressive this is not
default aggressive mmm-hmm bias for
action this is not taking action but
default aggressive and bias for action
biased for action is what the Marine
Corps says they want Marines to act they
want them to have a bias to actually do
something they want to buy us to take
action default aggressive is a chillon
front this is me telling young junior
officers in the SEAL team hey your
default has got to be go take action
make something happen but both bias for
action and default aggressive neither
one of those say 100% go hmm no its
default meaning that's what your default
is but you might have to adjust it bias
for action doesn't mean you take action
means you lean towards taking action
sometimes you need to look at the
situation and say you know what it's
gonna help here nothing
the best weapon the best weapons for
coin do not shoot counter insurgents
achieve the most meaningful success by
gaining popular support and legitimacy
for the host government so how often is
it that you as a leader can make more
progress by instead of telling someone
no we're gonna do it my way
instead of shooting them in the face
with that you say okay your way sounds
good you make you increase your
legitimacy as opposed to decreasing it
when you fire one off in their face the
host nation doing something tolerably is
better than us doing it well hey as a
leader when you got a subordinate leader
you know you can do it better than your
subordinate but it's oftentimes better
to let them do it good enough if a
tactic works this week it might not work
next week if if it works in this
province it might not work in the next
you got to keep an open mind you got a
change you got to adapt tactical success
guarantees nothing when Colonel Harry
summers allegedly told a North
Vietnamese counterpart in 1975 that
quote you know you never defeated us on
the battlefield
end quote the reply supposedly was quote
that maybe so but it is also irrelevant
end quote military actions by themselves
cannot achieve a success in coin
tactical actions must not only be linked
to the operational and strategic
military objectives but also to the
essential political goals of coin
tactical success guarantees nothing as a
matter of fact it's irrelevant in court
according to this North Vietnamese
colonel last one
most of the important decisions are not
made by generals it's the competence and
judgment of soldiers and Marines at all
levels senior leaders must set the
proper tone for actions by their
organizations with thorough training and
clear guidance and then trust their
subordinates to do the right thing
preparation for the tactical level
leaders requires more than service
doctrine they must also be trained and
educated to adapt their local situations
understand the legal and ethical
implications of their actions and
exercise suborn its initiative and sound
judgment to meet their senior commanders
intent you had a company in an
organization as the CEO as the CEO o as
the president as the guy in charge most
of the important decisions are not made
by you they're made by someone out there
on the front line so you better lead
them correctly
little section on successful practices
and unsuccessful practices I'll read
some of the unsuccessful practices place
priority on killing and capturing the
enemy not on engaging the population
what does that mean that means when you
have a problem inside your team and all
you do is attack like whoever you think
is doing it that's where your priority
is instead of building relationships
with the group you're wrong so when
you're a little kid and someone I don't
know broke the water heater and no one
wants to fess up so when your dad comes
and says uh someone tell me or else
you're all ural you'll all get punished
is that sort of the same thing like you
shouldn't know that that's collective
punishing and it's I don't I don't I
don't really agree with collective
punishing there are times where it's
used for instance in team-building
exercises like SEAL training yeah you
know you're gonna get that all day long
yeah oh yeah one person makes a mistake
there and make everyone pay and they're
doing that actually to create some sort
of friction right what's wrong with you
like keep your head on and about we're
gonna keep doing this until Charles gets
his head under the boat yeah it's kind
of like a - little pronged effect right
one you you want to put more heat on
that guy because like letting the team
down a lot of times there's more
punishment than letting yourself down
especially when they're all right there
and then the other part is yeah that
friction and then some stress on
everybody let's do it
I remember football they we there's like
okay so you know okay in football easy
said you know do you say what's called a
cadence you say set down Hut or go or
whatever right the quarterback says it
whatever so if you jump if you start
before the actual count you know you you
call for false start
offsides yeah depending on office
defense you know people call it
different things sometimes so anyway
there are certain drills like to drill
that in your head
it's always it's like an ongoing journal
anyway so if so if we're gonna do like
some conditioning or something it'll be
in the conditioning so everyone will
line up let's say it's wind sprints
they'll be like okay the county is on
three slowly a little set down hut hut
hut on the third Hut and they go some
people still jump offsides during the
conditioning seem saying it's like a
drill that constantly goes so if one guy
jumps off sights everybody pays for it
and sometimes the guy who'll jump
offsides doesn't pay for it so don't
calm out be like you just go ahead and
sit down Charles
yeah or basically in a wind sprints
situation is a common thing in our
situation would be like okay let's say
it's a 50 yard wind sprint right you
start at the death of zero yard line and
you run to the 50 or whatever um so
Lizzie it's the Council on to set down
how it one guy jumps off site I could
echo jumps off site echo stays there
everyone else goes five yards back so
now they have a 55 yard wind sprint I
only have a 50 I do it again they go
five yards back again soon saying so it
like it puts way more pressure on you to
get it right so you so you do blern I
think but some people can get into this
weird dunk downward spiral because
they're so stressed about everyone mad
at them now so they don't even think so
they can't like get their get their act
together it's funny but it's a good
really Korean stressor yeah some of the
successful practices the other
unsuccessful practices are you know very
sort of military based conduct
battalion-sized operations as the norm
that's too big concentrate military
forces in large bases for protection we
know that that's not gonna work focus
special operations forces primarily on
raiding like hey we're gonna go capture
kill bad guys that's not where you want
to put the focus you could do you need
to do it for sure but it can't be the
focus so that so then the some of the
successful practices are emphasized
intelligence focus on the population
their needs and security focus on the
population focus on the people expand
established and expand security or is
isolate insurgents from the population
so those are the kind of things that
help out place police in the lead with
military support
we absolutely tried to do that we put
the Iraqis we brought the Iraqis with us
we put them in the lead so those are
some solid successful practices and
here's the summary from this first
chapter counterinsurgency is an
extremely complex form of warfare truly
war at the graduate level at its core
counterinsurgency warfare is a struggle
for the support of the population their
protection and welfare is the center of
gravity of friendly forces and a the
decisive terrain this is something that
I stole I think this is the third like
big thing that I stole from this to sort
of start selling counterinsurgency up my
chain of command was this idea that the
center of gravity the decisive terrain
in this fight was not an airfield it
wasn't a part of town it was the people
if we got the people like you know when
you when you storm a beach once you get
the beachhead you know you once you get
a foothold that's the that's the
decisive terrain or if you're taking an
island you want to get the high ground
here it wasn't the high ground it wasn't
the the the beachhead wasn't the
airfield
it was the people gaining and
maintaining that support is a formidable
challenge there are a host of
non-military agencies who efforts must
whose efforts must be synchronized and
coordinated with those of military to
achieve these aims and this this thing
closes out insurgents are also fighting
for the support of the population but
are constrained by neither the law of
war nor the bounds of human decency they
do anything to preserve their greatest
advantage the ability to hide among the
people these amoral enemies survive by
their wits constantly adapting to the
situation to defeat them it is essential
that counter insurgent forces develop
the ability to learn and adapt
rapidly and continuously so learn and
adapt rapidly and continuously seems to
be a common theme here on this podcast
in the books that we review in the
people that we talk to in the lessons
that we learn we seem to hear it over
and over and over again as one of the
primary and most important attributes of
winning so I think it's pretty clear
that you need to take lessons like this
and if you can learn to apply them and
you can't universally apply them right
there's no and it says in the book it
says you can't just universally apply
these things that you always have to be
smart enough to pay attention to run a
feedback loop see what's actually
happening and adjust and you can only do
that by the way if you're humble enough
to to actually listen to the feedback
loop hmm
everything is related everything is
connected and you can overlay these
things into whatever part of your life
you need to to counter whatever
insurgency that you're facing whether
you're on the battlefield whether you're
in business you're a leader you're
you're facing an insurgency in your own
family and we also have to pay attention
the fact that we might have an
insurgency going on inside of us an
insurgency of weakness
and sloths trying to bring us down
echo Charles yes sir do you have any
recommendations how we could fight the
internal insurgency that we are facing
every single day well it's there 100
percent there okay you know when you
when you got a workout planned mm-hmm
and then boom you feel the battle going
on inside all the reasons why today
should actually in what think about it
today should be arrested that's the one
side you know on the other side is like
nope shouldn't be a rest day in fact
you're weak right now and let's get
stronger let's push there's a lot of
physical benefits and if you overcome
this feeling of not wanting to do the
workout and you do it anyway that's even
now you're getting stronger mentally too
and now you know but meanwhile it's like
boom it's a little battle the other side
but you got all that other stuff you
could be doing that you need to do you
got this stuff to do if you get that
done boom you'll be way better off I'm
just saying you'll get some recovery you
know so it's like two battles going on
insurgents are in there oh yeah and
they're 2n it's like that when you said
the insurgency on the inside it's that
it's the weak part of something to me
before home go ahead and good let the
cat out of the bag right there so if I'm
working on something right whatever it
may be and it's time for the workout or
whatever like that part of me would be
like God just do it tomorrow do the
workout tomorrow cuz look you got all
this thing that you're in the middle of
getting that done is actually better
right now where it's beneficial you know
that insurgent is trying to win the
heart in mind of my whole actions assume
saying mmhmm like it's showing me the
benefit you know of like skipping the
workout but it's kind of evil in a way
you know but you know we gonna fight
against that anyway so yes so what are
we doing well we're working out yeah for
sure let's get the work out don't skip
you're injured skip the workout today
was today this very day sure i well i
knew looking at my week ahead cuz what
is the day of the week it is saturday
right now yes so I looked at the week
ahead and looked at tomorrow did
pretty booked up tomorrow and the whole
week is kind of crazy mm and I know that
we needed to get this done so my first
thing you know I always wake up early in
morning workout but I knew I had to
prioritize this and I actually got it
done pretty quick God you know I had
already read it so now I was going
through making notes and whatever and I
but I woke up and did that first before
the workout before the workout because I
had to prioritize and execute yes sir
understood so now it's like you know I
spent like three or four hours finishing
the reading looking a couple things up
and then I was going through you know
highlighting so now it's like 10:30 or
something like that I had a little food
and I had all kinds of excuses no it
locked and loaded that's yeah so so what
I did was you had a little insurgency
going on yeah and then I just texted you
and said hey one o'clock let's do it and
I said as soon as if he's I don't care
if he responds or not I'm just gonna get
after it before I eat I like legitimate
food yeah waiting up that's a little
work oh yeah just went knocked out a
workout yeah yeah just did sort of a
combo workout it took me 40 minutes you
know what I'm saying still falling but I
just had to get it done you know had to
get it done had to overcome that boil
insurgency situation cuz sometimes those
insurgents can make good points there
make they know what they're doing yeah
they absolutely know what they're doing
that's why you got to be able to counter
um man I was thinking this let's face it
insurgencies are successful often yeah
yeah they're not if you don't know how
to counter on you're gonna be in trouble
big time what um so I was thinking this
yesterday when I was working out same
way you were that one time you're
teasing me about squats or whatever you
were like or would interfere cool Scott
remember you're saying that okay so I
was kind of the same inverse reverse
whatever scenario where I was like I
wonder if jock who could do this workout
like what if me and jock low traded
workouts whatever given day and we had
to do the same workout same weight
everything if you can't do it oh there's
an indicator you can't do it kind
thing right so if you can't do it it's
an indicator that you can't that's the
purpose of training workouts you know
like you always wonder like I wonder if
I could do that guys workout I wonder if
I could do that you know that that
football players weren't know whatever
you know you kind of wondered that every
once in a while especially when you see
guys working out hard like I think you
know these CrossFit guys or whatever so
that's what I was thinking I was like I
wonder if I I wonder how I would fare
with Jacko's workout because there's two
kind of kind of kinds of like road
blocks if you will one is like if I just
can't do the weight like let's say your
squad is just it's a bigger squat than
me you know so if you got freaking a set
of 20 a set of 15 and seven nine and a
set of how does however that goes and
you're you and I gotta use your same
weight and I simply can't get 20 reps
with that weight I just physically can't
do it it's kind of okay there's that
that's one then the other one is like
this is like I got a tap out this is too
hard for me I gotta rest more or I gotta
like not do ten sets I can only do like
five or whatever you seem saying there's
that too so both of those and probably
there's other stuff too is like you
wonder how would I fare in that exact
workout same you know weight like we're
now work similar weight as far as body
weight whatever so it's like I was
wondering that like I wonder if then I
was like first I was wondering I wonder
if I could do chocolates and I was what
then I was thinking I wonder if he could
do mind I don't think I could do yours I
think that there's be a Venn diagram
whether it be an overlap in the middle
where we could both do each other's
workouts then I have some workouts that
you wouldn't be able to do and then you
have some workouts that I wouldn't be
able to do it yeah cuz of our
specialties right the met cons I feel
like I don't know cuz yours are more
extended right your met cons they're a
probably like what 15 20 minutes or
something yeah or more yeah see so but
they're gonna be less intense though
depends
nonetheless I was wondering man so maybe
one day we're gonna see we should train
straight up have the workout I've rest
period built in too late
that's that's one thing is yours seems
more structured yeah you know I guess
not right I guess not really cuz but I
just basically I don't have rest periods
yeah generally most of my workouts don't
have like a rest like a time where
you're like three minutes of rest I
don't generally have that yeah yeah I do
for sure because where I'll be doing
some other exercise during that period
yeah which is yet another type of like
work up you know like stimulus free
because let's say you're just let's go
okay let's go basically example if you
go you know five sets of twelve we'll
just say alright there's a wit there's a
huge difference with not only the weight
you can do but just overall what you're
doing to your body for that workout if
you go one minute or s in between those
sets and three minutes are us in between
those sets you're doing like essentially
you're doing two different things to
your body yeah you know so it's like
alright which workout am i doing then
that's what that's why rest is is kind
of set in there but then if there's no
rest in between the sets and you program
it like oh I need to get 500 pull-ups I
don't care how I get them I just gotta
get them I don't know as fast as I can I
guess or whatever or just you just got
to get 500 pull-ups it's kind of that's
part of the workout too you know so it's
like it's almost like it's you're doing
a specific thing to your body there too
you know so it's like that fit you know
you don't have to have rest periods and
I program him in for a reason
see I'm saying ya know you have a
specific purpose but nonetheless forgot
yes I'm gonna tell people how we can
stay on the path yeah effectively
healthy mm-hm and you know effectively
and healthy anyway yes so when you're
working out you're gonna eat meat for
you will eat good 80/20 is good 80%
clean 20% freedom 80% this one 20%
freedom yeah interesting
well diet like that's recommended you
can go 19 you start going 70/30 then you
you think that's a slippery slippery
track that's what I think nonetheless
you want supplementation for you
joints for your brain for even protein
supplements boom we got you chuckle few
supplements joint warfare rejoins
obviously krill oil omega threes all day
and antioxidants by the way also
discipline and discipline go which are
essentially the same thing different
delivery systems cans and powders it's
true on demand and pills and what they
called gaps because I told I told
belittle at the beginning so we started
making discipline I said hey man this is
really good stuff
yeah this is exactly what I this is what
we want right I said but I talk for long
periods of time for living and if I have
to drink this to get my get that hitter
if I have to drink this before I go out
and start talking and then all the
sudden I gotta go to the bathroom I said
I need a pill I told him I said I said
put the stuff into a pill he goes okay
and he made what is it called it's a
compressed not a capsule but like press
the thing whatever yeah and I don't
really like those afro so then I had to
send him back bro and he goes he said
you he said you said pill and I said I
thought the same thing you take a pill
right I didn't know that a pill was up
whatever that compressed thing is and a
capsule is something different yes but
if you need that little like you need it
boom you can take a capsule discipline
got a pill not a gel cap which actually
this stem from so I forget what happened
in the world but there was controversy
about veterans and drugs and someone was
saying something like you know what do
you expect to happen when he's put all
these vets on drugs put on an feta means
and I said I said we're not on
amphetamines and he goes pilots take
amphetamines and I said I texted Dave
Burke yeah good deal kid yeah and I
I said did they give you guys an feta
means to take and he goes no I mean this
is all of within this is this is on
Twitter this is probably two years ago
he goes no and so I go back to the I go
no they never give pilots and feta beats
and then I get it as soon as I tweeted
that Dave Burke good deal yeah he goes
back to us bro I just screwed your oh I
just screwed you and I was like what he
goes you as they definitely give it to
us and I and I was like and I I was like
Roger I said hey I was wrong but guess
what they call them go pills okay so
that's what I was saying to be little
I'll said hey man we need go pills you
know we don't need an feta means in the
in fact do not want amphetamine but we
do want the feeling that discipline and
and the the the discipline powder gives
you yeah little cognitive kick yeah a
little-little get up and go yes that's
why we call it this one go anyway so
there you go
that's little information behind that we
got Jocko whitey we got Molk strawberry
chocolate for kids
we got mint peanut butter the whole nine
yards and all the stuff is available to
Vitamin Shoppe or it's available at
origin to Maine dot-com you know
speaking origin Maine other things on
there besides charcoal feel like these
in rash guards for jiu-jitsu one we go
back to jiu-jitsu if we haven't already
we're kind of getting back there and
boom I think there's a underground Nomad
there's definitely people training
that's Jamie's training Texas is open
yeah yeah there's oh I think I heard a
thing that gyms are opening June 15 Thor
something like this they opened with a
bunch of restrictions yeah so yeah but
we're getting there
yeah coming out from the underground for
sure so you gotta need a new key yeah or
Jinky best ones factually in the world
by the way and fully in America of
course in America yes of course which is
kind of important right now because you
want to get your stuff that's made in
America not made in China mm-hmm yeah
that's my recommendation anyways agree
don't forget about jeans don't forget
about boots
don't forget about t-shirts hoodies and
don't forget about joggers unless you're
me if you're me don't get jogger
yeah just forget about yeah don't Lee
there's a hole a hole just a hole can
there's a hole just plethora of reasons
why if your name is Jacque oh don't get
joggers they just don't work yeah don't
just not meant to be
don't put them on just if your name is
echo Charles Oh all day all beggars all
day oh yes sir
yes orgy bank.com also chuck was a store
that's called Jocko store.com that's
where you can get your shirts custom
shirts maybe you stretching that word
custom for well but nonetheless you
can't represent this one equals freedom
good take high ground higher ground take
you get after it it's a good one you
know it sure it's that wool Reppert you
can represent on the path while you're
on it's masking other cool stuff so yeah
if you like something get something uh
we have an email list here's the thing I
always feel kind of odd for like a
better term saying hey sign up on for
our email list it it feels weird saying
that well that's because you have been
conditioned in your life that every time
somebody told you that and you did it
you got a bunch of junk yes it's bad and
I don't want to see spam necessarily but
yeah it's one of these things were and
all I'm down I am down for the email
list hundred percent if I'm like oh wait
I do want updates on this stuff right
here I come down I'm not conditioned
necessarily against it but here's the
thing I have felt the sting of signing
up for the email list hoping that I'll
be updated with like new cool stuff that
they offer or whatever but meanwhile
they're sending me like oh happy
Valentine's Day from xyz.com
it's like bright I don't care about you
wishing me happy Valentine's Day in my
email inbox which let's face it our
email inbox for most of us for some of
us will say I think most of us but
whatever our inbox is kind of sacred
like prostate out of there if if you
don't have something look see this way
it should be yeah so anyway my point
there is if if you sign up for this
either you're saying all this now you're
gonna tell everyone that should sign up
for the no I'm not saying anyone should
do anything ever maybe not ever but I'm
not saying in this case but I'm saying
we do have an email list if you do want
updates and here's basically what I'll
we'll send out is like if there's a new
design or a new Hoodie or a new whatever
that's it pretty much for the store with
the occasional and when I say occasional
I mean very occasional exception where
if there is like some important
announcement an important is like there
it has to be very important what's an
example of an important announcement
that's come out on the email list
because mine has come out yeah none
okay that's right I said we got any
important yes I'm just saying none have
been but I'm saying if there was like
hey freakin no podcast for one month or
you know something that like I would
anticipate a bunch of people trying to
email me are you about then maybe but I
mean I can't think of anything offhand
specifically but it'll be really
important I think I will firmly believe
that it's important anyway
otherwise you're just gonna get new
stuff every what once a month maybe once
every two three months yes maybe anyway
I'm not gonna B's you that's what I'm
saying I realize that everyone's inbox
is sacred okay so I'm gonna okay where
do they sign up for this email address
list thing on choco store.com at the
bottom should I make some kind of an
email hey okay I don't think so you know
leave everybody alone that's like what
people are all into like oh yeah you
know and I dig it if it's that's like
the what do you call it that you're got
an email from somebody that's like like
you sign up for an email list and then
you get an email but it says is from
like the person you go oh it's from
so-and-so but then it's just a mass
email yeah
well because sometimes it is from that
person but it is a mass email okay but
sometimes it's from like their marketing
company yeah
whatever is the ones that I go come on
man yeah but I felt all good but well
this one is good because it's actually
from me yeah so I'll try to make it look
cool and official you know pictures on
there but but yes it is coming from me
I have friends if that you know kind of
have email list right yeah sure and and
I'm on their email list but then I'm
also have you know will exchange
personal emails right about whatever
topic and I'll get an email from out
like an email I'll show up and I go oh
that's cool so and so and then I open up
and it's one of those things like I'll
do a bummer yeah
what do you mean like sam harris just
whoever yeah you name him I signed up
for some Harris's email list but it was
happened to be at the same time where I
sorta like medam and sorta like no man
that I seen it like from summer I was
like yes so where's his emailing me and
then it's like he's podcasting I was
like I felt that cool I signed up for a
reason so I was like sir but that
expectation that it's actually him
emailing you be like hey great to meet
you or something like this you know yeah
that's funny and no I get I get it but I
get you know quite a few friends like
that you know where and you know I don't
I'm not a big communicator and I don't
have a ton of friends anyways so when I
do get emails from my friends it's
always because I get a lot of business
emails obviously but then when people
email my personal email you know when I
go up and then I see that it's a for me
meow but sometimes it has spurred me to
email them right I've gone you know and
then they email me back and we have a
cool something no but it reminds me yeah
yeah I say why what gave me that feeling
like oh that's cool to hear from this
person or that person
mm-hmm maybe they were thinking the same
thing why am I not emailing them well
Who am I supposed to not not taking an
initiative here yeah I'll take some
initiative and say hey I listened to
your last podcast or hey I saw you do
that thing and they go all cool you know
what I mean
you know so it's a little indirect
prompt to kind of relate to people yeah
reach out man yeah can't pick up a phone
yeah it's true all right well
nonetheless there you go so yeah
chuckles store.com that's where all this
stuff is also if you want to subscribe
to the podcast on iTunes I know sounds
kind of weird cuz you're probably
already or subscribe maybe maybe I don't
know I yeah you yeah me too chuckle but
if you're not subscribed subscribe boom
let me remind you that that option is
available for you we also have some
other podcasts we have a podcast
formerly known as the thread which I was
this close to renaming and I and I
didn't like it and I found then I found
the ultimate new name for it and there's
already another podcast which I can't
even believe exists with this name that
I can't believe has already been taken
so I'm still in the midst of finding out
a new name for that well what was the
name I'm not gonna say it why not
because it's just I'm not gonna say
you're so let down I was so disappointed
and also I want to see if there's a way
that I can still manipulate the name
enough to use it
alright but but I don't want to give it
away
grounded podcast where we talk about
jiu-jitsu which we talked about
jiu-jitsu say a lot anyways so but we
talk about it even more and we talk
about life and we talk about everything
else on the ground in podcast we got to
warrior kid podcast for your warrior
kids we got warrior kids soap from Irish
Oaks ranch calm a young warrior kid
making soap so that everybody out there
in the entire world can stay clean
we got a YouTube channel which is where
EKKO takes videos and he puts him on
there sometimes he puts modifications I
said last time that he should he should
put enhancements into just the podcast
so when I talk about counterinsurgencies
when I talk about weapons some things
should happen in this you didn't do it
whatever total lack of initiative but
it's all good I'm sure there's someone
out there that would love to modify
these things yeah well you know to me
the jury is still out whether or not
that's a good idea so you know what I
don't want to think about it why don't
we test it why don't we see
next time when we do this podcast you
know you make your little notes you get
your little e yeah a little baby like oh
when I talk about all there was this
massive explosion you could just make a
little nut guy says one hour and 37
minutes explosions in you here's the
thing jack for somebody that freaking
just puts explosions everywhere yes sir
yeah and I'm an explosion advocate as
far as video goes 100% but here's the
thing here's the thing with that so
let's say I put a cool machine gun sound
explosions you know whatever I'm going
whatever we put and one single person on
YouTube with one of those ghost accounts
that like you know no profile picture
one of those guys says that's corny
brother it's gonna like devastate me
I think us okay we can do it that's an
indicator hard enough also we got
psychological warfare a bunch of me
talking about your moments of weakness a
little psychological hitters we got
flipside canvas little visual hitters
flipside canvas comm support the coda
Meyer while you're at it we got a bunch
of books the code the evaluation of
protocols leadership strategy and
tactics Field Manual way the warrior kid
one two and three Mikey and the Dragons
discipline equals freedom Field Manual
extreme ownership and the dichotomy of
leadership
check out those books if you like what
we talked about on here national on
front that's our leadership consultancy
I talked about it a couple times today
we solve problems through leadership
that's what we do go to echelon front
comm and by the way if you want me to
come and speak to your company don't go
to a speaker's bureau and don't Google
jaco speaking just go national on front
comm that's what we do we have EF online
which is revamped come and check it out
it's online courses it's online not just
online courses online interactive you
want to talk to me if you want to talk
if you want to hang out with me in a
zoom meeting you get on the EF online
comp and you will get
that's why we'll be sitting there
answering your question muster our
leadership seminar event gathering
Phoenix at Arizona September 16th and 17
we're doing it
Dallas Texas December 3rd and 4th we're
doing it every gig we've ever done has
sold-out extreme ownership calm if you
want to come to that and if you need
leadership in your organization go to EF
over watch.com we got military prior
service military personnel that
understand the principles we talked
about and they're ready to come to work
at your team also America's mighty
warriors org
momily mark lee's mom she's out there on
the grind helping in a multitude of
different ways servicemembers
active-duty their families gold star
families around the world that's what
she's doing you can go to America's
mighty warriors org to either get
involved or just donate and if you
haven't had enough of my protracted
discourse or you need more of echos
arbitrary tails you can find us on the
interwebs on Twitter on Instagram and on
Facebook echo is adequate Charles I am a
chocoholic and thanks to everyone out
there in uniform right now trying to
keep order from becoming chaos and
you're doing it voluntarily for us and a
massive thanks to police and law
enforcement out there firefighters
paramedics EMTs dispatchers correctional
officers Border Patrol Secret Service
you do some of the hardest work in the
world you don't make a ton of money you
do it with massive risk for yourselves
and you do it to keep us safe and we
thank you and to everyone else out there
there are lots of insurgencies going on
lots of insurgencies happening in your
life in your business and your
relationships and your family in your
self it's real easy just to say hold the
line it's real easy I say it all time
but you got to remember all these
complexities you got to remember that
more than just brute force you have to
use your mind you can't just outmaneuver
you have to out think you have to give
and you have to take you have to think
strategic and you have to play the long
game and it's not easy but that's how
you win so go out there and get after it
and until next time this is echo and
Jocko out